[Müzik]
Ben eğlenceli bir sürüsünde bademin
gösteren bir şey getir sahibi
bugün Eğlencenin insan hayatındaki bir
olasılığını kulağa olan yansımasında ve
buradan bize neler
in eğleneceğinizi
saklatmaya çalışacağız dünyanın başka
bir vakit finansmanıyım dertli kontrol
ü biraz Eğlencenin nasıl doğduğunu nasıl
olabileceğini işaret
leyenlere ve o da
Tabii ki daha doğru insanlara
yönlendirir şimdi burada bir örnek
korku nasıl oluru sizin de şöyle görelim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
devamında
ise Eğlencenin
oluşum Hani aslında başka insanları
çevremizdeki insanlar ailenizi
çocuklarımızı eşimizi sevgil
imizin yani evlenirken gördüğümüzde
Biz evlat Biz Neyi çok güzeldi sözü var
diyor ki ben diyor disneylan
diya karar verdiğimde
çocukluklarda nasıl eğlendiğini
gördüm Aslında bir hikaye oradan başladı
Yani onların mutluluğunu gördüğü zaman
böyle bir şey yapması gerektiğine karar
vermiş ve şu anda
yaklaşık olarak yılda Belki de 50 milyon
gelir partnerinize ziyaretçi olarak
kabul ediyor ve geldiği noktaya
baktığınızda tabii
ki tekrardan bir tanesi
dir biz bu için walkbook'a teşekkür
etmemiz lazım diye düşünüyorum yine
dediğim gibi yani aile çevre eş dost
Ahbap empati spiker konu bu da aslında
Doğru tam olarak
Bu başkasının mutlu gördüğümüzde biz de
mutlu olmak isteriz ve bunun için de
neler yap
abiliriz bunu tasarlarken başka
mutluluklarını Ben buradan mutlu olur
muyum Evet o zaman Başkası da olabilir
ve Onu gördüğünde ben
bunu Evet ona göre tasarımda direk
dediğim gibi açıklama mıyız Diğer
taraftan benzersiz eşsiz deneyimler
sunmak yine bizim eğlenceli endüst
risi çok çok kullandığımız Aslında
Eğlencenin üçüncü yöntemi
bu böyle ya da bildikleri gördükleri
Nihayet ya da Ee Harry Potter
dünyayı insanlara yaşatabilir bu eşsiz
deneyimler bize hiç daha önce
yaşamadığımız deneyimleri sunduğu için
eğlencede şaşırtıcı etkisini Aslında
sunma şansı sağlar Ve tabii ki burada
biz biraz teknolojide kullanarak
eğlenceli şaşırtıcı etkisinde
özel alanlarda
geldiğine bakacak olursak bu iş
[Müzik]
müjdesi
Henüz daha Kone ağırlığında
ve biraz
uzak bir
Eğlence nasıl döndürüyoruz
döndürüyoruz dolaştırıyoruz ufak böyle
hafif 20 kilometre saat 10'da gidiyoruz
en fazla da biraz böyle daha fazla
[Müzik]
Tabii yukarıya zıplat
IR ya da bugün belki 100 yıldır hiç
değişmeyen yine çok önemli arkadaşlar
sorulardan bir tanesi Muhtemelen de
milli parklara gittiği zaman çarpışan
araba vurursanız edinirsiniz
[Müzik]
bu nereye geldi
bu şu anda nerede
[Müzik]
şurada
hızla gidip koşturda formülü
[Müzik]
olan ve onların
yaşadığı döneceği artık teknoloji ile
birlikte verdik bu noktaya geldik
peki Yani daha önce hiç gidemeyeceğiniz
bir yere nereye
[Müzik]
gidemem içerisinde bu simülasyonla
birlikte uzaya çıkartırız
maden top
ayın hikâye sana
sorayım Mars'a Götürebiliriz ya da
isterseniz kampanya dağlarında sizlere
çok Efsane bir deneyelim o yüzden
teknoloji Görsel işitsel ve diğer yeni
yeteneklerle
biz bunları teknoloji ile birlikte en
tegre aslında burada daha önce size
göstermiş olduğum o görsel işitsel
teknolojilerin yanına büyük devasa
cihazlarda yine sizin Normalde parklarda
gördüğünüz ama deneyimleyemeyeceğiniz
türde gerçekçimiz deneyimini
görebileceğiniz bir eyer uygulamasını
gösteriyor belki
arkadaşı daha önce hiç gitmediğiniz
bir şeyler yani
Çin Seddi'nin üzerinde uçuş deneyimi
nasihat
lar da artık yaşayabiliyoruz
biraz da eğlence endüstrisine
teknolojinin nasıl katkı sağladığını
aslında sizinle konuş
mak sosyolojik anlamda
Entegre olmuş teknolojinin olduğu bir
eğlenceli bir
sürsün yine disneyle ilerliyor sorular
Bunların hepsi en çok aslında bir görsel
kişisel teknolojilerin hepsini fazla
kullanan firmalar olsunlar yine Tabii Ee
eğlenceli
faydası var inaksiyon kontrol dediğimiz
Fikri uygulamalarda da benzer bir
teknik görmüş olduk Çünkü fitney
mülkiyet haklarındaki Mesela işte Az
önce bahsettiğim gibi bir mezopotro
dünyasında eğlenceli bir ülk
E daha güzel Ürünler ortaya
çıkartabiliyorsunuz ve bunun yanında
Tabii ki bu katkı olarak da son 10 yıl
içerisinde teknoloji yüzde fazla eğlence
en
dişesi çıkan ve giriş
yapını sağlamış bulun
uyor yine
hacmine bakacak olursak da aslında
buraya küçümsememek
adına insanlara mutluluk vermenin
yanında bir de ayrıca teknolojik
ile beraber bu işin reel ekonom
iyi bularak olarak baktığımızda 500
sağlıktan sonra en büyük
Özel sektör yani Real ekonomiye ciddi
bir katkısı var Eğlencenin süresini bu
Avrupa'da bu sayılar yaklaşık 100.000
civar
ında milyar dolarlık bir temelinden
bahsediyoruz bu hacmin içerisindeki Real
ekonomiye katkısı
hele hele
de bu dünyaya Mutluluk veren bir eğlence
Endüstrisi hem Reader mutluluk veriyor
bu oldukça başarılı
gibi aslında burada bir Trambolin getir
ip Ama tek
Dolayısıyla
Az önce bahsettiğim o M4
hormonlar nasıl sağlıklı büyüyebiliyor
musunuz Aslında değil olarak bir şey
hissediyorsunuz bir şey görüyorsunuz
şaşırıyorsunuz
ayaklarınız yerden kesilmek istiyor ve
zıplıyor zıpladığınızda daha fazla eğlen
iyorsunuz
eğlenceli
Biz gülen yüzler görüyoruz
eğlenceli endüst
risi paylaşılarak çoğalan bir şeydir
eğlence de aynı şekilde
bunu eğlendiğini gördükleri ve ortamda
kendileri de eğleniyorlar
ve eğlenceye mutluluk çerçevesinden
bakmamız
gerekiyor
çıkıyorum ahşabanın bir kısım
ve kendisi hala hazırda Belki de benimle
birlikte dünyada Vicdan fazla eğlence
ünitesinde
dolayı Her seferinde daha fazlasını
istiyor E tabi O daha fazlasını isterken
doğal olarak yanında babası Hanginiz
daha fazla eğleniyoruz bazen diye
düşünüyorum açıkçası
[Müzik]
arkadaşlar
eğlence
bulaşıcı çok teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]